Along with big-budget disaster flicks and
edgy rom-coms, thrillers with a strong female
lead were a huge part of the cinema landscape
in the 1990s.
Whether it was Sandra Bullock tracking down
conspiracies in The Net or Julia Roberts escaping
an abusive spouse in Sleeping with the Enemy,
audiences were eager to see women taking on
nefarious men.
Few films personified this trend as well as
the Ashley-Judd-and-Tommy-Lee-Jones-starring
revenge tale Double Jeopardy.
Beware: there are spoilers ahead.
In the film, Judd plays the quiet and kind
Libby Parsons, whose wealthy husband Nick
vanishes while they're alone on a boat.
Although Libby is clueless as to what's happening,
she's eventually convicted of Nick's murder
and sent to prison.
But, plot twist, Nick is very much alive,
and he purposefully framed Libby for his death.
After one of her fellow inmates clues her
into the legal concept of double jeopardy,
the idea that someone can't be tried twice
for the same crime, Libby vows to use this
loophole to make sure Nick doesn't get the
chance to enjoy the new life he's created
for himself.
The plan: She'll falsely admit to murdering
Nick in order to be released from prison on
good behavior, then kill Nick for real, as
she's already been tried and convicted for
that particular crime.
While the core idea of Double Jeopardy is,
well, not exactly legally airtight, who really
cares?
The movie is an enjoyable slice of late '90s
thriller fun, which is probably why it's currently
on the list of top 10 movies on Netflix.
"Kinda makes you feel warm and tingly all
over, don't it?"
But back when it came out, the movie took
a beating from critics.
The late Roger Ebert was more charitable than
many in his two-and-a-half star review, though
he still called the film,
"...not a successful thriller, but with some
nice dramatic scenes along with the dumb mystery
and contrived conclusion."
Entertainment Weekly described the movie as
"toothless" and "a strained reworking of The
Fugitive."
Reel Views wrote,
"Unfortunately, this movie is too focused
on action, melodrama, and plot twists to allow
for more than a moment's intelligence to worm
its way into the script."
Despite the middling reviews, the movie was
a hit with audiences.
It spent several weeks at number 1 at the
US box office, and it raked in nearly $178
million across the globe.
Considering its current popularity on Netflix,
it's clear that something about Double Jeopardy
has always connected with the general public,
despite the silly plot.
Reviews credited Ashley Judd for her performance.
Though Reel Views critiqued the movie as a
whole, they did lavish praise on Judd's performance,
saying,
"Ashley Judd almost makes Libby credible.
In fact, the actress is so good that, against
all odds, we like the character even though
she only uses about 1% of her brain cells."
Double Jeopardy has gone on to become one
of Judd's most noteworthy roles, but her part
in the film originally went to another actress.
According to an interview in Urban Cinefile
with the film's director, Jodie Foster was
originally attached.
He explained,
"She fell out of the project, because she
got pregnant, and we had to recast.
That's how Ashley Judd wound up in it."
Second choice or not, the movie helped cement
Judd's status as a go-to star for thrillers
with tough women at their center.
Before Double Jeopardy, she starred in Kiss
the Girls, along with Morgan Freeman, a film
based on a popular James Patterson novel which
sees Freeman's Detective Alex Cross on the
hunt for a serial killer named Casanova.
Judd plays a would-be victim of Casanova who
manages to escape, and then partners with
Cross to help him track down the killer.
After Double Jeopardy, Judd teamed up with
Freeman again for High Crimes, where she plays
a lawyer who finds out her husband has been
hiding his participation in war crimes.
And following that, she starred in Twisted
as a San Francisco police officer with a drinking
problem who finds herself at the center of
a conspiracy when her former lovers keep turning
up murdered.
Unfortunately, Twisted is also notorious for
having a one percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
But clearly, even over two decades since the
release of Double Jeopardy, audiences are
still connecting with her portrayal of a woman
hell-bent on revenge.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.